[Applause]
hi I'm Jeremy Brock welcome to the third
of BAFTAs 2018 international
screenwriters lectures in conjunction
with Lucy guard and the JT Charitable
Trusts on this winter evening we are
enormous ly honored to be hosting the
internationally renowned writer and
director Nicole holt sneh Nicole's body
of work from her 1991 film short film
angry - 2018 s the land of steady habits
spans nearly 30 years of acutely
observed forensically funny examinations
of contemporary life issuing all the
predictable tropes of comedy in favor of
a of a realism that is both startling
and poignant a universality from the
specific Nicole will talk followed by a
Q&A with the writer and journalist in
Hayden Smith after which as we always do
we'll open it up to the floor so ladies
and gentlemen Nicole
Olaf singer
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I've never stood in front of one of
behind one of these things before ever
hi everybody thank you very much -
coming for coming to hear me speak yeah
I'm a little nervous
I like being behind the camera but this
is challenge for me and I think it's
gonna work out
I want to thank BAFTA for having me here
it's a really big honor I was thrilled
when I got invited so thank you so much
um I am gonna read I'm gonna try to have
some eye contact as well but I like
having this thing here the last time I
had to stand in front of an audience to
tell them why I was special I peed in my
pants I had been proudly sharing the
wonders of a cactus that my cousin had
given me when I was visiting
Philadelphia and it was going well until
I was peeing the urine burned its way
down my white tights and into my shiny
black Mary Jane's head onto the floor of
my first-grade classroom quick on my
feet I said to the class you might be
wondering why I have this water around
me you see it was raining a lot in
Philadelphia and now and I stepped in a
puddle and now my shoes leak I was
pretty confident they believed me until
my best friend told me that everyone
knew is he so I've been invited to this
prestigious event to tell you how I'm
talented and I'm afraid that while I
might think it's going well a friend of
mine will polite would let me know that
none of you bought it because you all
know it was pee
okay no more pee talk I promise I don't
want to give advice except to say the
cliche of follow your own voice because
I don't really know anything else
I only know what's worked for me and I
didn't even know I had a voice until
other people told me I did I'm writing
what I want to write about and if you're
doing the same and not trying to fit
into somebody else's idea of what a good
story is your voice will appear or at
least it should and it doesn't have to
be autobiographical for it to be your
own I am gonna try to talk about how
I've taken various stages of my life and
turned them into screenplays because if
you've seen my movies you know they're
all kind of personal because I write
about myself I feel exposed a lot of the
time but when it works when I feel like
I've written something that moves people
whether it's funny or sad then it's
absolutely worth the exposure like
standing here right now
I write about my problems my friends my
lovers my fears and of course my mother
sorry mom um she adopted a baby black
boy when she was in her 50s so he grew
up in a family of white people mostly
women I wondered what that was like for
him and it inspired me to write lovely
and amazing
I turned my brother into a girl for a
variety of reasons he was thrilled
in this scene Annie I'm gonna show you
clips by the way she feels lost among
her sisters neurotic problems and walks
by herself to McDonalds her sister
Michelle played by Catherine Keener is
always annoyed with her and Annie feels
like Michelle doesn't like her this is
the scene actually towards the end of
the movie from lovely and amazing yeah
my my brother actually really loved the
movie but he was unhappy that I made him
overweight which at the time he kind of
was not anymore um okay so I wrote
enough said because I thought you know
what if my boyfriend's ex-wife told me
what his faults were or about the stuff
he did that drove her crazy would that
be valuable information or would it ruin
my own perception and experience of him
having been married before I clearly was
afraid there would be hidden parts of
this new person that were eventually
going to hurt me as I continued to write
I gave the characters children who were
about to go away to college and that
gave them something to bond over my own
kids hadn't left for college yet but I
was consumed with not wanting to let
them go and not wanting to start this
new phase of my life without them the
empty nest became a large part of the
movie kind of Eden inadvertently
I don't plot things out so my scripts
reveal themselves to me as I go along
so because of this I usually end up with
some shitty first drafts but that's okay
the first draft is always the most
difficult and scary but rewriting can
actually be fun it's much easier for me
to see what I'm doing one
I've done it let's see
so here Eva and Albert have their first
date before she knows anything about him
it's so touching to watch Jim kind of
kills me
so later Albert discovers that eva has
coincidentally but coincidentally become
friends with his ex-wife Catherine
Keener and has heard an earful making
her judge everything about him and so it
all goes to hell that's the next clip is
that normal that everybody collapsed
after a fight it's nice I'll take um
sometimes writing about personal things
can be cathartic and sometimes not at
all one would think that if I write
about my fears I would be able to
conquer them but it doesn't always work
that way
here's another scene I guess the last
one from enough said about me taking my
kids to school basically I cried while I
was directing that scene actually a few
people people on the crew did as well I
mean it was just so emotional watching
her performance and I kind of can't even
watch it now like my kids have gone to
school but it's still like I'm wrecked
did it lessen the drama when I actually
took my kids to college cuz I shot this
before and no it did not um
unfortunately movies are movies in life
is life um so I have this thing about
the truth I believe that a lot of time a
lot of the time truth should trump
manners and can we even say that word
anymore did he actually steal a verb
from the English language it's like
that's all anyone thinks that when you
hear that for instance if a good friend
asks if I can tell he's balding and I
can I
the truth because I'd want the truth and
I assume others do but of course that's
not always the case if I'm insecure
about something and people keep telling
me I'm imagining it like no no you don't
look that way whatever and people keep
telling me I'm I don't feel relieved I
feel placated and once I got a really
shitty haircut not once but several
times should I'll tell about once and
was so happy when a friend said yeah you
got a really shitty haircut it was such
a relief I was like right it helped that
somehow someone saw what I saw and
validated my feelings it diminished its
importance simply by calling it what it
is it was a tragedy however this is from
please give and this really points to
needing for someone to see what I see
and to be seen that feels bad right it's
like I look fine is this fine and then
we can play the next clip because it's
connected so um in my life and if you've
seen my movies I grapple with what it
means to be a good person what to give
and how can be tricky and not so obvious
in the beginning of please give a be
them asked her mom Kate for an expensive
pair of jeans and Kate snaps at her
telling her that they're you know
hundreds of homeless people everywhere
and that she's not going to buy her
teenage daughter $200 jeans which seems
reasonable except that Abby continually
watches her mother give to everyone else
but she turns out to be a nice girl of
course Abby seemed spoiled and obnoxious
but she's crying out for a mother to see
her throughout the whole movie it's not
about money she believes the jeans will
make her feel better and eventually at
the end of the movie Kate gets it she
realizes that giving can be an
intangible thing I'm talking less than
the clips but that's okay with me
thank you on how to be good topic I like
to volunteer and have many have had many
experience expeller
I've had many experiences doing it that
turned out to be completely unhelpful
and even detrimental hey once and this
is just one of many I once carried an
old mentally ill woman woman's groceries
to her apartment and gave her my number
in case she ever needed anything she
left threatening messages on my phone
machine for weeks convinced I was trying
to kill her
once this was the kicker once my mom and
I went to a mental hospital I'm like
Rikers Island to sing Christmas carols
to cheer up the patients I don't know
what we were thinking
honestly oh my god it was so sad it was
so sad I ended up in the stairwell
sobbing I wrote this scene to make fun
of my own useless and harmful attempts
to be good that's me
[Applause]
when I got to set that day I was mad at
myself for even writing that scene
because I was afraid I was gonna end up
falling apart just like cake does that I
would feel so bad and only feel pity for
those kids and end up sobbing in the
bathroom it was me directing a scene
about my limitations while I still had
those limitations I didn't fall apart
and ended up enjoying myself but it was
a very meta
whatever the epitome of me and my movie
blending together so I have this thing
about truth but I also have a thing
about justice you see if you make movies
you can get all the [ __ ] out um I should
have been a judge but even better I'm a
judgmental person who gets - who gets to
point out how incredibly screwed up and
disappointing people are in my movies
I'm appalled when someone builds a huge
house that looks like Bloomingdale's or
Harrods next to a tiny one blocking
their light privacy and views don't they
know that even before they move in their
neighbors hate them how could they
possibly rationalize their selfishness
this this one's from friends with money
I wrote that part of the movie so that
those kind of people will hate
themselves when my kids were young
other moms sent their nannies with their
kids to play so they didn't know where
their kids went this scene from friends
with money is about me wanting to call
people out on their obliviousness
sometimes when I get caught up in the
pleasure of deep moral outrage I can't
see what's right in front of me that the
problem is me next scene I don't behave
like that I swear I don't
well maybe sometimes and then I'm a fool
I can be tough on characters based on
people I know oh no I skipped something
wait Jane is depressed because she feels
she has nothing left to look forward to
she feels old and irrelevant and is
pretty angry about it she wants justice
not that I can imagine what that feels
like okay show this scene from friends
with money see if you act like that you
look like an idiot um I can be tough on
the characters based on the people I
know she's based on a friend of mine for
sure but I'm tougher on myself that
doesn't make it okay to take my friends
crazy behavior and use it but I'd do it
anyway carefully though carefully most
of them are happy to lend themselves to
me some are not in the end I'm writing
about my own blind spots my own
immaturity and my own unlikable
qualities the character and please give
that you've already seen some of and
Gilbert playing is based on my granny I
mean I made an Gilbert look like my that
was my granny up there um and so I just
I wanted to show you a scene that was
kind of reminiscent of my grandma but
she wasn't well anyway just watch it
it's funny watching that I feel like it
is like my shadow it's the stuff I'd
want to say to my grandma but I wouldn't
she did talk about her aging body a lot
and in complete denial and it made me
sad and so I get a man to Pete to scream
at her for me over the years people have
said to me that I should get out of my
own head and life and write about things
I don't know why don't you mix it up
challenge yourself you know write a
thriller and it makes me question myself
like I'm not a real writer
unless I make everything up but if it's
so satisfying for me to write the way I
do why should I do it someone else's way
yes if I make bigger movies that I have
more money and better goodie bags
I love goodie bags but I'd rather stick
to what I'm doing no one should ever
listen to anyone anyway as William
Goldman said nobody knows anything and
it's absolutely true there's no right or
wrong way there's only your own way and
it is ironic that as I am writing the
speech I'm not writing a new script I
can't
I've been stalked and blocked and I'm
afraid I'll never write another script
again my friends tell me that every time
that I say that every time and but there
is a time when it will be that time and
how do I know this isn't it when I'm
writing I feel alive and valuable and
grounded and when I don't I don't feel
those things very much it's hard to
believe that something will come but I'm
gonna trust and hope that it will
because making movies helps me feel that
life and all of its [ __ ] up Beauty is
more than the sum of its parts
that's the end
[Applause]
what cocoon I get a Christians you want
one
yeah very saggy chair but very writer
Lily we're gonna pretend we're like in a
little salon just realized why I had the
cushion on this seat sinking over the
course for the next 40 minutes I'll
disappear yes I like being upright
you've talked about your work as a
writer director there's an enormous body
of work as well that you've directed for
television if you don't mind I'm gonna
stay mostly with your work as a writer
director but also your work as a writer
I have total faith and trust that your
career is going to continue as a writer
director because I don't think anyone
who's written the body of work that you
have so far will just come to a halt
I just think well maybe I'll just start
writing some really bad ones it happens
but with the idea of a career continuing
um yeah I'm quite curious about the
whole Afsaneh extended household perhaps
starting off with your sons when you
announce that you're writing a new
script mm-hmm is there a sense of
nervousness in your family of like oh
god what I'm gonna do next or um no I
don't think so cuz I don't I don't go
bananas or become a drunk or do anything
like horrible that my kids would be
upset about it's more like I think I
have an idea what's it about oh my god I
don't know I can't tell you yet um so no
you know they don't care that much I've
read a number of interviews where you
talk about your upbringing and you had
some quite incredible experiences within
the film industry because of your family
it was there's one amazing one about
Warren Beatty we're not going to talk
about it here you have to go often
research but it struck me a side of
friends with money and Jason Isaac and
Catherine
Sheena's couple who are writers yeah
you've dealt with artists you've dealt
with therapists masseuse but you haven't
indulged in the Hollywood world have you
ever been tempted to write about Holland
yeah definitely but I haven't come up
with the story yet I had an idea about a
famous person stand-in or you know an
assistant to a crazy actress which would
be really fun for about 20 pages and
then I don't know what's supposed to
happen next that it doesn't become silly
and ridiculous you know but it's yeah
it's an interesting crazy business I
mean I love movies that are about the
movie business I love the player day for
night which I have not seen in a really
long time but that made me want to make
movies that really fun it's interesting
that idea of fun because I was saying
earlier that one of the great pleasures
of being asked to host this event
specifically is indulging in your work
over the course of the last two weeks
and it's been an absolute joy to watch
your films I think it struck me that we
shouldn't have to pigeonhole a director
writer director in in in one single area
but reading a number of interviews and
profiles of you people talk about
romantic comedies which i think is
completely incorrect and then there's
Ariel Levy's profile of you for The New
Yorker which is entitled human comedies
because your films are very funny but I
would never think of them as comedies
yeah the dramas with humor in them right
how do you see um I would call it a
comedy drama it just is a shorthand but
the drama on this moat in those movies
are so it is so important to me it's
great to get a laugh but you know if I
can move someone to tears then I'm
really happy or just feel really moved
by something
and I don't know I can't help being
funny I it's like I write a sad scene I
don't mean that in some obnoxious way
but it's like I'll write a sad scene and
suddenly I've made some jokes you know
and sometimes they work and sometimes
they don't but I guess I like to lighten
things up I hate melodrama I just hate
that so we had like a boy chichi
speaking about his process earlier today
and he talked about the fact that it's
much harder to write comedy is to write
straight down drama mm-hm and I'm
curious about your process you've talked
about where you draw your ideas from
right but the actual nuts and bolts of
it your daily process I use someone in
who is regimented you sit down you won't
leave a table until you've written so
much um it's sporadic
I mean having raised kids it's hard and
I will avoid writing at all you know in
any way possible
you know the laundry and the whatever
now there's online shopping which is
really [ __ ] because then you're in
your doing it and it's right there you
know I type on the computer
and then you get those pop-ups and it's
like Oh a sale um my my ideal thing and
I've done it from the start is to get up
early and write for a couple of solid
hours that's that's a good day for me
if I can focus and sometimes I can get
many pages written sometimes I don't and
sometimes I don't do two hours or the
three hours when I'm rewriting something
either for a job or for myself that I
can sit there a lot longer and time goes
by faster but writing an original ISO
kind of depleting coming up with ideas
that I just have to fall asleep
sometimes with a pen in my hand though
as you're watching price has changed
over time
normally no I mean in the beginning I
tried to follow what I was told in
school you know the 30 pages first act
and the wants and the protagonists and
the all that what your valid things but
I couldn't follow like if I plotted it
out and put the cards up on the wall I
got bored and also when I get to write
the scene
I wouldn't regard the cards I just like
oh that's a boring thing and I'll just
write it anyway differently so I don't
do that and I just like I said I just
come up with an idea and take some notes
about characters usually and then blend
them together with some kind of
hopefully a plot or a situation and
there I go and like it's easy to get
stuck that way but I like it are you
someone who has a repository of ideas of
snorri's
because it's interesting watching all of
your films together mm-hmm
and and seeing the way that you map end
the narratives and obviously they are
character driven and utterly credible
characters characters we'd imagine
seeing on the street every day but there
are certain scenarios that I wonder
actually was that something that you
heard from a while back and yeah awesome
and you bring your names or are all
these scenes specific to the film that
you're writing oh yeah that I don't have
a drawer full of ideas I really wish I
did I could make a drawer of bad ideas
that I would never end up writing but no
I have to kind of wait for an idea or
inspiration and for instance this script
that I'm not writing anymore you know I
did have inspiration I was really
excited and I got 2:30 and it was
terrific and then I just couldn't get
past 30 it's easy to get to 30 right
like you know you set everything up it's
fun and then okay how do you keep
everyone awake um so was that your
question
the same yeah but also within that
process you talk about plot and it's
it's very interesting I think there's
certain genres the people tell you are
particularly critics might take for
granted and say well you know this is a
relationship drama it's what do you
expect right and again looking at your
work there's something quite radical
that happens I plot
why's I just feel that you see the plot
as being far less important to character
and characters in the situations and so
what I find really fascinating watching
your films is the character arcs of your
films there's not the grand arc where
there is this epiphan all redemptive
moment right at the end of a film yeah
she buys her kids jeans yep that's right
Stannis I mean I feels like it's the
every day that you're dealing not it's
the ordinary not the extraordinary right
but in itself the ordinary becomes
extraordinary yeah but like with friends
with money that makes me think of that
like the idea started with the fact that
my good friend bought the apartment next
door to hers in Manhattan and had to
wait for this old woman to die so that
they could break through I'm sure it
happens here and um and I thought this
is crazy and my friend would bring her
lasagna and yet it was all under this
relationships like are you dead yet when
can I get in there and she wouldn't die
it took a really long time and I thought
what a crazy idea and then but that
wouldn't have been enough then it was
like okay so their neighbors and the
grandchildren you know feel like they're
you know bloodsuckers and so that gave
me all this great stuff to work with
you know neighbors who have to differ
different agendas and yeah but then that
in a way taps into what you were saying
earlier about trusting people to tell
you the truth and be honest with the
truth and I thought you've given us an
example a moment ago of an instance
where someone is being truthful but in
friends with money you've got Jason
Isaacs character that we've seen with
the house building and he comments on
the size of his wife Catherine Keener
SAS saying how big it's gotten and it's
very interesting because they it seems
that you you do say okay this is a
spectrum right and on this spectrum you
can
too far right that was just that was
just plain mean you know on their
marriage is ending and she says he is
horrible breath and they just kind of go
at each other so yeah there's truth and
then there's truth you know I think it's
I can probably be too brusque with my
friends
she said she read this speech I said I
want your opinion and she's like oh god
I remember what you said to me she was
like do I have any cellulite on my
thighs and I said yeah you got a lot of
cellulite and she was like stunned and I
don't remember saying that but she
didn't she wasn't mad at me cuz again it
was kind of like that she knew she had
it I wasn't gonna say she didn't have it
so within that I can talk about
cellulite pee what other disgusting
things affect this table but within that
and again this to me crosses all the six
films that you've made the idea that
audience sympathy that's not earned is
an overrated cinematic virtue the
audience sympathy in so many films is
something that's taken for granted by a
filmmaker and it strikes me that's not
you're happy to present characters who
might be slightly misanthropic and by
the end of the film we don't necessarily
love them mm-hmm but there's at least an
understanding for them and that's that's
quite unique for someone who's exploring
that throughout much of they work that's
probably why I have a small career
seriously I don't
I like ambiguous endings you know I mean
my goal is I want you to like all the
characters at the end I do even in land
of steady habits when ben mendelsohn
does some rotten things I want you to
still like him why I just because I love
these people and they're highly flawed
and they [ __ ] up big-time
[Music]
but I don't know I still really I have
compassion for them
I'm trying to think who I don't have
compassion for my movies I don't know
I'm staying with the land of steady
habits which is now on Netflix available
to watch and you mentioned ben
mendelsohn quite a bit of has been
written about the fact that this is your
first male central protagonist in one of
your films but watching it it struck me
and you've gone we're going into the
realms of God our desk and Tarantino
asked here he is a very hollofson Aryan
character right watching it I thought
well okay yes this is this is a central
character hmm but this is very much in
keeping with all the other characters
yeah it didn't that's why I was drawn to
the book I adapted it from a novel and
yeah I just I felt like he was really
screwed up and makes some reprehensible
mistakes but he's funny and still
charming and learns and is a buffoon a
great big one and you know he it's much
darker than my other movies in terms of
what happens and I totally understand
when people say they don't forgive him
or you know they couldn't get behind the
character because he was so unlikable
but I get that and I knew when I was
making it it was like that but I
actually told Ben I was like you're my
Catherine Keener like he was just I I
felt like I was directing a woman and he
was very flattered that I said that I
could take it you know he's really
sensitive it's also interesting in that
you follow on from working with James
Gandolfini who we saw a moment ago both
Ben and James in your films are
completely cast against type right that
must have been quite interesting just
playing with their persona yeah it was I
mean people you know Kenny can that
actor do that you know I've never seen
Ben in a room you know be a nice person
or sort of a nice person but that's
exciting you know it's a risk but
actually it's not a risk people say you
really took a
and some Jim James Gandolfini you know
and it's like no you watch The Sopranos
that guy can do anything and he's
heartbreaking
so yeah it's fun and do you enjoy the
actual casting process I mean yeah it's
like did I say that out loud it's really
stressful I mean it's exciting when you
know I call Ben Mendelsohn he's like
yeah I can't believe he said yes you
know but some actors take forever
or I can't find what I want or you know
the worst-case scenario is that the
studio wants me to cast someone else and
I don't want to cast somebody else and
I'll kind of make a compromise like okay
I'll I'll offer to that big star in that
big star but not that big star and then
they don't get back or they are busy or
they want more money and I mean in terms
of Netflix it was at Fox Searchlight and
I developed it there but we couldn't
agree on a cast and I said I want Ben
Mendelsohn they were like we can't do
that he's a great actor but we can't do
that so Netflix agreed to do it so it's
like casting is hard it's hard because
usually I want to cast like Mike Lee you
know I want like buck-toothed people and
you know the zits and the whatever the
real thing but I can't in the film
you've got Edie Falco who's wonderful
playing Ben Mendelsohn's ex-wife and I
wondered if at any point in time you had
a phone conversation with her sort of
akin to Gregory Peck being offered a
comedy and him on the phone going so
he's Cary Grant not available or
something did you have a conversation
where de fogo wish like yes it was
Katharine busy oh right yeah um I don't
know if she probably did she was like
well I mean what um and I just I love
Edie I've loved her for years wanted to
work with her and I don't even know if
catherine was busy but she we have an
understanding you know she's like you
can actually cast someone else
and and I did and you know it's just I
want to sometimes work with other people
I do and well I'll come back to
Katherine and Julie I help another
person in the film a lot of study habits
is is Connie Britton mm-hmm and her
character highlights something again you
can see in all of your work and it comes
back to your writing process that I'm
curious about I could be wrong and I'm
perhaps being a little pejorative here
but if the land of steady habits had
been made by a male director mm-hmm I
get the sense that the female characters
would have been bit parts mm-hmm and
Connie Britton is this woman that and as
the main character meets she's only in a
couple of scenes but she is a fully
fleshed out character and I'm just
curious within your writing process
about the attention did you play to so
many different characters long yeah well
some male directors some are brilliant
and some male directors might just shove
them under the rug but I don't know I
just if I'm I'm pretty aware if I'm
writing a character that has no
personality you know
um and I struggle like I got to give
this person a personality you know
they're just kind of standing there and
sometimes I'll just cut them out if it's
not working and I can't because they got
they just got to be interesting and hold
people men or women I just you know all
my movies I get not always but you know
critics will say like she gives short
shrift to the male characters and why
not you know - and then I did Lander
steady habits and I got she gives short
shrift to the female characters and it's
like oh my god you know some people have
smaller parts what are you gonna do um
it's also the another element that you
can see in all of your work is there is
a really strong sense of place and this
this even includes can you ever forgive
me which opens here early next year
which you wrote not directed
but in the writing you get such a sense
of early 1990s New York and can you talk
and in the case of land of steady habits
we've got Massachusetts films New York
and LA can you talk about how you
incorporate I you know it's not
something I think about it's like where
it takes place and then the characters
are just in that place like I mean I
didn't write I adapted can you ever
forgive me from memoir and in the memoir
it's very clear that it was in the 90s
and it's this bar and that Street and
where she lives and so I didn't have to
create that so much but in land of
steady habits is Westport Connecticut
and you know I don't I don't know from
that you know I'm Jewish I don't if you
don't know Westport I was like the only
Jew there I'm kidding it's not that bad
but you know it's very waspy and you
know men wear shorts with little whales
on them and stuff and and so I had a
costume designer she just did a bunch of
research and you know showed me pictures
and was like oh I like that kadia
sweater oh I like that Brooks Brothers
suit you know every department really
helped in that way and I really wanted
the houses to look very different you
know like Edie's house is warm and the
family house you know with history and
his place is cold and sterile and new
but I was also very limited in terms of
exteriors because we shot New York for
Connecticut and we couldn't shoot in
Connecticut and it was freezing
so we kind of didn't do that much but
I'm thrilled when people say oh it
really feels like Westport Connecticut
like how did you get that like you just
said it's like I don't know I can't
entirely by that because they think of
that well another thing about your
writing is that it's it strikes me that
the way that you approach class which
doesn't exist in America apparently no
now an economics and even occasion when
you you touch on race and touching on
politics
you very such a very specific sense of
place mm-hmm well I love that stuff I
mean anything you know class and race
and anything that's taboo to talk about
like money or race or politics that's
really fun too right and really fun to
direct I find and so if that gives it a
you know a sense of place maybe or fills
out their lives in a way I think I know
what you're saying and have you have you
felt any sort of reaction within your
writing process of we saw your short
from 1991 so we are moving from a
Republican president through to a
Democrat president through republican
than democrat and what there is now a
dictator yeah you said it I mean I'm
just I'm just curious if about the
impact of that as you're writing uh-huh
the way that climates have changed I
think I'm Way too self-absorbed to put
that in my writing I mean it's in my
it's in our world it's in my head but
I'm not writing about that stuff I'm
just not other people do very well but I
stick to the human details so with that
idea of self-absorption something that I
noticed that well there's one obvious
scene between two characters Charlie
time and Ben Mendelsohn's character the
last scene that they have together which
watch the idea of parallel play that
this is something that I see in a lot of
scenes in your film where you you have
two people talking mm-hmm and they might
be hearing but they're not listening
yeah I need it's something you do so
well in your work thank you it's never
happened to me before I mean I mean half
of me people are not listening to
anybody half the time I mean most people
are not most people but I you know I
find it very difficult when I can tell
someone is just thinking about what
they're gonna say next
I mean I've even had interviewers which
you are not one
terrific but like they'll be like
they'll have their pen in their paper
and they'll be like you know so you you
know you write about this male character
who is you know obnoxious and I start to
answer and then they're like this and
then I'm looking at them like Who am I
talking to it's just really
uncomfortable and that's sort of the the
biggest example of that
you know because most people will just
you know whatever but that scene in
particular I did want parallel play in
the boat you know they're not they need
each other in some crazy way and they're
both so immature and sad and lonely but
they're not really talking to each other
and they have absolutely nothing in
common which i think is what makes ben
eventually say like we've got to get out
of here
I know it's one of the things that I'm
particularly in that conversation
certain things that Ben says I mean this
this idea that of the ordinary the
everyday that I could imagine hit
someone on the street saying something
like that again Taika Waititi earlier on
today mentioned he's newbs dropper
mm-hmm oh yeah that's fun yeah that was
gonna be my next question
yeah which Bernie's dog I don't run
around with a pad but I remember some
certain things and I will go home and
write them or if I have a pad or a phone
but that's the most entertaining thing
and now my my thing is like looking over
people's shoulders when they're on their
phone like if you go to a movie
everybody's on their phone first and you
can just like watch the [ __ ] that
everybody's doing or you know
interesting conversations or they're
flipping through their Instagram and
it's such a way in to their lives but I
yeah that the stuff people say it's just
you can't make that [ __ ] up let's some
take some questions from the audience if
we can raise the lights and we've got
some roaming mics so there's someone
down here and then anyone further back
yet in someone right at the back so
we'll go this one here first and then
back row hi Nicole
hi how did you get through your writer's
block before and what you gonna do to
get through your writer's block now that
you've got well I guess you're supposed
to just keep writing but and so when I
was writing the script that I can't
finish I just kept writing and write
scenes and I would get to page 80 and
then I'd read it and it was bad and then
I did that a few times and then finally
I just said I can't do this anymore
and I gave in to the writer's block and
I felt immediately relieved because I
just couldn't nail it and I'm sad and
I'm scared and I don't plan on going
back to that I might take pieces
eventually out of it because I think
there's some good stuff in there
so I don't know I mean um I can work
thank God in TV directing other people's
stuff which I really like and I'm
reading things like books and scripts
that I could direct and adapt but those
are you know mostly money money jobs I
enjoy doing them but it's not the same
so I'm kind of looking around for what
might be next and that's how in other
words I I don't know how does the
freelance directing help in any way in
sort of freeing you away from your own
absolutely
yeah it's great and if it's a show I
really love and I'm so excited to be
there and also like ultimately I mean
unless I really screw up it's not my
fault because I'm writing so I'm
directing somebody else's material the
writers and producers are right behind
me and so after every take I are after
the end of a scene I'll turn around and
say can I move on are you happy with
that and if they say yes then it's not
my fault and so and plus I get to meet
new people new actors I want to work
with and directors and I mean the other
crew members but it is a relief and
that's why I want to do that now I want
a job so I don't have to think about
this but writing is the most satisfying
thing
having written is the most satisfying
thing finishing a script is thrilling
yep I was interested to hear and to read
about earlier your are you at the back
right at the back hi
your early experiences working on Woody
Allen sense and Hannah and her sisters
is an assistant editor
I was just wondering how maybe you some
of that has influenced you if at all
because both if you kind of have a very
kind of like personal cinema and
autobiographical in in some ways and I
think um my relationship with Woody
Allen is completely overblown in so many
publications like he was not my mentor
he was not a close friend you know and
when I worked on Hannah and her sisters
I was an apprentice editor I just sent
the dailies which us old people will
know what that means
you know and I interacted with him and
he he you know was a family friend ish
but I think that I was inspired by him
just like everybody else
it's not because I knew him I just loved
his movies especially the earlier oh
there was sorry woody but they're still
unbelievably hilarious and and beautiful
those older ones um you know many other
directors like Mike Lee and Albert
Brooks and a lot of filmmakers who wrote
really personal stuff you could feel it
was personal all that inspired me then
you know I think seeing Sex Lies and
videotape when I was in film school
really blew me away because that felt
like I mean I don't know if any of that
stuff happened to Steven Soderbergh it
probably did but it was so normal and
regular and slow and quiet and felt so
real that those kind of movies inspired
me to someone here and then we'll go to
the front and then over this side
hi Nicole hi I was born very aware of
despeezo sorry hi hello I wonder what
your views are on the changing landscape
of films in terms of Netflix and Amazon
Prime because it strikes me that your
kind of films and these sort of more
grown up comedy dramas or even romantic
comedies that I feel like you've saved
one's the screenwriters coming through
that this seems to be now the home for
these kind of movies yeah and yeah I
just wanted what your your thoughts were
on that sort of you know in a way
presumably that's exciting there's a
bigger landscape but does it mean that
you know these sort of movies won't be
seen in cinemas so much and does that
does it bother you where your films are
seen for example well I'd much prefer
have to have my movies in a movie
theater I knew that land of steady
habits was going to be a tough one you
know unless George Clooney was in it and
even then based on the material but I
wanted it to be screened in a theater
and then when Netflix that I could cast
anyone I wanted I didn't care about the
theater anymore I was like that's the
point I want to make a movie I'm proud
of and so I got to do that now that I've
done that is a very strange experience
it's sort of like I made a movie and
then it blew away I gotta know where it
is and I don't see people watching it
and you know they have a very different
model of press and and long-lead
advertising like nobody knew this movie
existed a week and a half before it was
released
they're like you made a new movie I was
like yeah there's no trailer there's no
this or that like months in advance
nothing they blast it all at once like
two weeks before it's released and then
it goes away and so again I might go
that route again because it let me make
a movie I'm proud of but and so I think
the landscape it's good and bad
you know obviously anybody can make a
movie now and that's great it's not so
you know elitist and hard to break into
but you know just like you know I'm like
an old lady it's like
the iPhones and the you know nobody's
looking at each other and the movie
theaters are going away yeah oh yeah you
mentioned that you don't know what's
gonna happen when you're starting to
write your first draft yeah how much do
you need to know before you're ready to
plunge in and is the process of writing
your first draft something you just last
in a couple of weeks or anguish over
many many months that one I wish I could
be more and so we banged it out in two
weeks it's like I hate you who are you
um I write I start writing when I get
bored taking notes like I'll make up a
bunch of characters and a few scenes and
I get an idea of maybe what the end
might be like and then I just start
writing and I get completely lost
generally after a while and that's when
rewriting and rewriting and rewriting
helps you go back to the beginning of
what you've written and keep changing
yeah so you're so in a way you're doing
a new draft each yeah I don't know how
people count drafts you know I think
sometimes I mean I'll do all I'll do
that to a point and then eventually it
is does feel like a first draft still
and then once I like I so this is about
that then I can rewrite it but I do go
over it it's impossible not to see what
you did yesterday Nicole thank you very
much for an enlightening chat I'd like
your honesty today I think it's great my
question is about the actual but two
things is obviously about putting your
package together for your films and the
second thing is about using an actress's
Bank ability to actually get your film
made because obviously they're arson
actually say like the emma stones and
Jennifer Lawrence who are the names that
can open a movie but you're using
Kathryn Kim I mean how what's the
general feeling if you're trying to get
your films made do you can you rely on a
bank ability of an actress like a name
like that some would they consider a one
of your scripts I think certain actors
would definitely consider my scripts I
mean I get so impatient and frustrated
if somebody has to
too long to read the script I feel I got
you know I'll find someone who wants to
read it right away and I I offered a
part to Kate Winslet I think it was that
any remember which movie it was and I
loved her and really wanted her to do it
and it was taking forever like a couple
of months was going by and I told my
agent like let's just pull it back let's
tell her we're moving on and then I ran
into her like the week later and she was
like I was about to read your movie and
you took it away from me so I don't have
patience and but I sure I mean I loved
Emma Stone I loved a lot of famous
people and I would love to work with
them well you know they're busy and I I
do have some of those famous people who
say I want to be in one of your movies I
mean Melissa McCarthy and I have wanted
to work together for a really long time
but I'm not I guess I'm just I'm not
like a sellout I don't want to put
somebody in the movie just because
they're famous they have to be really
right for it does that answer your
question
okay hi hi I was wondering what is it
that you enjoy the most about the
writing process and what is it that you
dread the most that you feel you're
struggling with the most um the writing
well I don't know when I'm when I'm
reading it something I've written and
I'm laughing or I think I'm clever this
was good and finished having finished it
is the most satisfying but like if I
have a good day I mean it's just so
terrible how much it affects my
self-esteem and my worldview it's like
if I wrote a good day I feel really good
you know and if I'm struggling then it's
always a struggle though I guess
discipline I feel bad when I'm not
disciplined I find myself pushing it off
and that makes me feel bad so why don't
I do it every day I don't know it's a
conundrum
um hi Nicole so you mentioned that a lot
of your characters are based on your
real experiences and you draw on your
relationships of others is there ever a
fear of the backlash that comes with
that if somebody yeah
what Chisholm is your work and things
takes offense the way that they feel
they've been betrayed and how do you
deal with that um well it hasn't
happened very often I have I did like
show one of my scripts to the character
that you know she's point being
portrayed and read the script and said
no this is great I'm fine with it and
then when she saw the movie oh my god
I really hurt her feelings it wasn't a
flattering portrait of her and I felt
really bad I did and other times I'm I
try not to I did have one friend who
didn't want to see the movie because he
knew he was kind of in it and I don't
think he would have minded it but he was
kind of anxious about it I mean I would
love to just write so honestly about my
family and the craziness and the [ __ ]
you know all of it but I can't do that I
don't I can't it's not worth it until
they go until they're dead yeah I think
we got time for a couple more questions
very quite we've got someone at the back
either I have a question about when
you're writing script and then you turn
up on set and when you're directing a
scene do you find there's a difference
between what you've written and what you
find in the moment or how do you
approach that well of course you know we
picture it in our heads when we're
writing completely and then you get to
the location and it's all wrong even
though everything is different the way
an actor will say it is different and
usually for the better because I've cast
people I really want sometimes that's
exactly as I pictured and I'm thrilled
but I'm open to changing things while
we're shooting and if someone says
something terrific or funny I'll take it
I generally try to keep it to what I've
imagined and I don't know it's it's so
weird like I don't remember what I
thought that scene was going to look
like when I wrote it because then it
becomes something else and then when
you're editing it it becomes something
else again but it's cool being able to
direct your own writing I mean that's I
can change it I can do whatever I want
to it we touched very briefly on
adaptation but but is that more of a
challenge for you because I know with
the land of steady habits you the focus
is more on the central character mm-hmm
as his life is falling apart rather than
giving lots of lots of backstory right
the character of Connie Britton plays is
non-existent non-existent yeah in Ted
Thompson's novel so I I'm just curious
ready know I read an interview in which
you said that okay
yes I gave 30 seconds ago but thank you
but yeah it's I'm just curious about the
the sense of license the sense of
freedom you have and obviously then the
extra element if you're not actually
then directing right well I take license
and I don't think any novelist
should care I mean unless they I don't
know don't trust me at all Ted Thompson
was so thrilled that his movie his book
was being turned into a movie it was his
first novel and he was already a fan of
mine and he was such a pleasure he was
like do whatever you want go go for it
and I showed him drafts and he corrected
me in certain areas or Sneed suggestions
and that was good but adapting is easier
because it's the air already
I haven't had to adapt like a big fat
thing and Whittle it down into you know
most of the stuff I've adapted is pretty
manageable and picking and choosing I
would just like set the book up in one
of those recipe stands and you're like
this is a good scene that's a good scene
and just kind of do it based on what I
like and what I'd like to write and what
is important but it's easier for sure to
do that and can you ever forgive me
it was really fun to adapt her memoir
it's a really funny memoir it was kind
of a challenge to figure out how to get
well you guys haven't seen it yet but
how to get you know a writer on screen
to be interesting while she's writing
and while she is all these other voices
kind of that she's writing I don't know
I don't know I'm saying my saying if you
haven't actually seen all of Nicole's
films that she's written and directed
all of them except her first walking and
talking available to see in the UK
hopefully that will become available
again because I think it's a lovely
debut thank you just get it anywhere no
it's it's it's very old but I mentioned
a number of times near the land of
steady habits that is now
available to watch on Netflix and I
strongly recommend that you watch it
it's a really beautiful piece of
filmmaking can you ever forgive me
opens on the 1st of February in the UK
you get a chance to see it then and yes
it's by a different director but I don't
think Melissa McCarthy and Richie D
grant would be half as good if it wasn't
for such a superb screenplay about film
thank you very much for jayjay
charitable trust and to BAFTA for
organizing this event but most of all
can you please join me in thanking
Nicole
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]